Selena Gomez and her bestie Francie
Ariza opened up about their tough road
to recovery after the singer's
life-saving kidney transplant we
couldn't take showers by ourselves I
mean it was a really brutal process in
any situation you're in if you're with
the right group of people that's all
that matters
months after Selena underwent surgery as
a result of her battle with lupus the
popstar reveals the health challenges
that led to her complicated transplant
on The Today Show
I had arthritis I my kidneys were
shutting down I just kept my mentality
was just to keep going her roommate at
the time Francia explained how she found
out Selena was gravely ill she couldn't
open a water bottle
one day she chucked it and she started
crying and I said what's wrong and
that's when she told me and she goes I
don't know what to do the list of seven
to ten years long and it just vomited
out of me I was like of course I'll get
tested a quick decision that led to an
even faster testing process Francia
explained that because of the emergency
situation she found out if she was a
healthy donor for Selena in a day a
process that normally takes six months
to complete it is incredibly difficult
to find a match the fact that she was a
match I mean that's unbelievable I had
to write a will which is scary because
there's no guarantee your weight you'll
wake up thankfully Francia says post
surgery was smooth sailing for her but
Selena was not so lucky when she woke up
after the transplant I started
hyperventilating and there was so much
pain there Selena revealed one of her
arteries flipped causing doctors to pull
her back into a six-hour surgery I want
them to know it
okay I was okay with dealing with it now
the 25 year old singer says she's doing
better than ever as soon as I got the
kidney transplant my arthritis went away
my lupus there's about three to five
percent chance I'll ever come back high
blood pressure is better my my energy my
life has been better
[Music]
you